أجنبي،
هذه هي المشاهد الدرامية التي التقطها
أحد أفراد الطاقم التركي على متن
سفينة الشحن التي صعدت عليها القوات الروسية في
البحر الأسود، وقد
أُمر الطاقم بالجلوس على سطح السفينة
بينما كانت القوات الروسية المدججة بالسلاح تقوم بتفتيش
السفينة،
حتى أن هناك اعتراضًا لاسلكيًا مزعومًا
باللغة الإنجليزية
[موسيقى  ]
قبل لحظات من إطلاق طلقات تحذيرية
من سفينة الدورية البحرية الروسية
فاسيلي بيك، مما أجبر
سفينة شحن النفط الخام التركية على التوقف، وهي
المرة الأولى التي تطلق فيها البحرية الروسية النار
باتجاه الشحن الدولي
منذ خروجها من صفقة الحبوب التي توسطت فيها الأمم المتحدة
الشهر الماضي، ويقول المسؤولون الروس إنهم
الآن  يعتبرون جميع عمليات الشحن في البحر الأسود
من المحتمل أن تحمل أسلحة إلى أوكرانيا،
لكن الجيش الروسي يقصف أيضًا
الموانئ الأوكرانية
ومنشآت تخزين الحبوب ويمنع صادرات
المواد الغذائية أكثر من واردات الأسلحة
على التلفزيون الحكومي الروسي،
ودافع ضيوف الكرملين المؤيدون عن الحادث الأخير في
البحر داعين  إنه قانوني تمامًا
على عكس ما فعله الأوكرانيون
مع ناقلتنا الروسية، يقول هذا
المحلل الذي يقول إنها تهدد
بكارثة بيئية إنه يتحدث عن
هجوم الطائرات بدون طيار التابع للبحرية الأوكرانية على
ناقلة نفط روسية في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر
أيضًا في البحر الأسود، ويبدو أن كلا الجانبين
تستهدف الآن الصادرات الرئيسية لبعضها البعض
باستخدام القوة البحرية لإرسال
تحذير صارخ في أعالي البحار